gather around children Jesus you never
get in the middle Freddie no oh my god
ecology hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan
Simon I know this would be crazy we're
gonna watch the trailer I forgot that
I'll do what is it so silent hill's PT
trailer that's right I remember and now
they have a character that's based on
Norman Reedus yes the well he's going to
play it so he's actually is it like
motion capture yeah oh sweet it's pretty
cool there's some interest interesting
controversy because games con that
wasn't necessarily supposed to show some
of his footage but they did and so
there's been a little whatever but he's
gonna do the game okay so okay yeah
because he be the coolest [ __ ] guy be
a game should be awesome cuz it's not
like a zombie game so it's like Anna
shoehorning the walking dead guy in
there guys
it's just single handily most terrifying
experience over her life I'm excited I
love horror but I can't like do it by
myself I have to be with somebody when
I'm like watching or playing something
[ __ ] freaks me out but I love it I will
say the Silent Hill movie as well is
actually a pretty good video game
adaptation it's based off a game I'm
like yeah you guys bored in anyway time
but guess what I will be counting backs
and I'm bringing my new toys with me
oh god no thank you oh it's too real I
love it
that looks really good yeah this games
OAD Okajima does this yeah that's not
the only person that's involved with
this project
oh oh oh yeah mo del Toro's perfect for
this hello Norman very nice
oh he's the [ __ ] I would love to play as
him
creepy
dude you go let's like a game you have
to play okay Alex awesome that was the
that was the trailer I never got to ha
yeah that looks incredible I'm just
excited a tattoo yoga kshema and pharma
del toro combined game is too much I'm
already dead
I was excited before Bradley way excited
now Alyssa be excited
Alyssa be super excited guys I did pt it
[ __ ] was terrifying hey watch it I
watched one of his videos and I screamed
like a little girl terrifying as soon as
I heard that dude's voice at the
beginning of the trailer I was just like
that reminds it fits nope he was the one
that's like turn around I said turn
around you turn around and then you're
supposed to get killed but I would do it
the wrong time but anyway it's gonna be
scary as hell those two together are too
much it's too good everything everything
looks so damn good in that game just
like oh the creator's alone is what's
really getting me yeah that's like
that's like I would hear those two names
together and I'd be like I gotta play
this those makes for something
incredible it's [ __ ] Guillermo del
Toro's like how he does like creatures
and so oh do you the collector's edition
is literally coming with a pair of pants
yeah that's what I heard is really comes
with an extra pair of pants so they've
set out saying like I want people to
crap their pants
that's how scary this can I do gameplay
with you on that we'll see we'll see I
don't even know if I'm gonna play it man
would you guys like it if I did gameplay
with Dan don't these on him see this
little [ __ ] [ __ ] don't be that guy
I'm going to be that guy comment on
Dan's channel and let him know promoting
this video for that's fine I already get
like 80 comments a day saying you would
ride ship believe is that yeah if you
guys are new to the Channel please
subscribe please beg for the love of God
subscribing and Alyssa has a channel to
clean
please subscribe to her channel please I
would love you forever in effort and dan
has a challenge you can choose if you
want to do it or not ah yeah yeah and
Rob Hokkien see huh
grumpy happy harrumph II I am her own
thief
Rob Hawkins he said did you give me a
shout out yet or nah and you know what
Rob Hawkins I don't believe I did
I remember name like Hawkins so you know
that mean ah well then I guess there's
only one thing we can do we gotta shut
this [ __ ] out boy like paper
change all I want to do is the worst
interpretation I think we [ __ ] me
that's Rochelle Rob Eric Salif
he said um shout she's at shot it would
be cool just putting it there I I know
he meant shout out shout it yeah yeah
I'll give you a shout out I'm just I got
a serious problem with people who just
don't spell correctly it's an issue of
mine
I need don't be one of those just élisa
élisa be interrupting right now please I
was in the Spelling Bee competition were
you yeah
in my school how far I was one of the
first to lose but whatever [ __ ] boy my
Eric you get up you get a right oh
you're fine you get a write-off
yeah if you're right that's assassins
dead-end can i have a shout out please
yeah dude assassin said and you could
totally have it that's pretty cool
assassins dead-end that'd be a cool
[ __ ] movie yeah oh yeah I wash it
what did you that just sounds so sweet
is it like like oh man these are the
assassins dead end if they are coming
after you wonder if it's like we're
gonna have a meeting after this I'm
gonna give you my pitch because we don't
want these on the internet because one
brother gives it because he has
especially assassins dead he might
[ __ ] look we're gonna p.m. you we're
gonna talk about this oh you just wanna
secrecy here so we're gonna send a
10-page contract in point eight font we
want you to read over it initial sign
and send it to I'm not gonna say
addresses I should find someone I hate
and get their address just find someone
who's just really horrible kind of all
this crap consent but yeah SAS instead
end a good job on the name my friend and
don't worry we're gonna keep the movie
secret if anyone knows how to keep his
mouth show that's this guy okay I'm
anything but a blabbermouth haha
I think I can count the amount of
there's not enough fingers on my hands
to count the amount of Secrets please I
especially on the channel I'm very much
censored super sensor oh yeah yeah I
don't temperature really pay attention
to what I'm saying hey the most
conservative people I've ever met I
think there's a there's a shovel over
there which in my judgment yeah just
yeah thank you thank you so much about
here you go
you know only three out of five girls on
this channel have told me why did you
keep that in there and it's usually some
type of joke sex joke about them that
they're always like why'd you keep that
in there that's gonna make me look bad
that's like what you're not thinking I'm
you dig like they're why do you think
the list is not in the middle right now
because when we put the trailer here
you're still gonna want to see them
sorry that was driving the line that was
drawn the line I like getting slept
actually well come on
secret number living